I'm still wondering how you make his save
like that I don't know what are you asking me
for de AR who by the way got the second assist
on the goal in front oh what a sand Carter Horn
of Mattias scanar give hard a lot of credit he
sticks that pad out and stuffs it out right on
the doorstep look at that effort for him trying to
get that right pad all the way over there and that
pushes pushes gets his leg over there and stops
ym Mark point is in Bo oh what a stop by bosski
unbelievable Braden points had him dead to Riser
so he thought but barosi gets him with the glove
look at how with just that concentration
just watches that puck go right into his
glove send in forsberg to the front stolling
save miraculous stop from Hunter sheeper in
a tie hockey game Hunter Shephard entrusted
with the net mining duties and he comes up
huge here's a chance for Nick Paul and it didn't
go in it hit the post and stayed out and then Fox
with his glove batted it out of the crease oh
my goodness how did that not go in and yeah it
is fox fox comes and clears it away with his
glove nice little move how about that save
oh my goodness with the stick back backwards
and then that's where he getss the help from
Fox I thought it was the stick tun FR Kee robbed
by cocking and oh what a marvelous save by coo
cocking and robbing Adrien kempe that might
be the best save I've seen against the Kings
this year he reaches behind himself you see
the puck oh that he keeps it out now a break
for Hoffman and it's saved by lion great
Save By The Red Wing net minder Alex lion
there off the deaking Mike Hoffman and look
at the toe of the skate of lion making that
stop for cousins his shot blocker Sav s and
it was behind him and makoy behind the goal
tender batted it out of the air that
was on its way in and that is a beauty
on the backand no less and then he slides
into the net and watch this Jennifer he
still tries to not make contact with swayan
that's smooth that is really smooth Jeremy
San showing a little love for Charlie
makoy for helping out his stats a little
bit Nelson tries again n delovic answers
him again it's loose Alex n delovic with
the paddle Alex n delich how how did
he make those saves that was ridiculous
almost falling out of the booth here was
that one with reaching back of the paddle
he's still in there battling making saves
no Sticks no mas I'll throw everything out
there to keep that puck out than that oh
my goodness goalies are crazy but we love
them in the first five minutes big chance save
and the rebound stop oh quick everybody going
ooh and on to that one how about those two
saves the first one was excellent the second
one better and nobody can believe this save
what an unbelievable play by Jonathan Quick
I'm still wondering how you make his save
like that I don't know what are you asking me
for gosis bear his shot to a screen Rebound
in the slot Soros moving around Far Side a
diving F what that's save by Soros an absolute
Masterpiece sprawled out on the ice watch this
save by Saros the Superman save he's down and
out Tangled with mcdunn and he jumps across
and catches it with the glove watch this
he has no business making this save oh my
god oh he dropped a on Q wow wow just not able to
get that puck up higher up and under the bar and
Joey dord flashing the leather here is Alex leerer
lurking around the net centering pass and thre how
did that stay out my goodness what a fabulous save
from Stuart Skinner and there's that puck up for
grab steuart Skinner the last second realizes hey
I don't have this Puck it's gone through he has
to stretch with the glove and takes it away early
that's knocked away but he got it back shley out
fromont they what a stop by flurry and neita Rider
can't believe it he had the hatrick all squared
away well NE Rider gives him a head knot I to say
Well done what a save that was sent towards an
redirected save and Elvis a second save with his
almost his back to the play got the right pad on
it backto back stops by m leans H wow looked like
Dawson Mercer had an open net he leaves for a lot
Scot L around ref around and the Smith just got
back with the left p man there was a lot of net
there for a moment brilliant work by the Smith
as he's got to react quickly he knows he's got to
go here turn over for Thompson Pass for Skinner
oh my what a save terasoft kicks the pad up and
kept that one out wow yeah that was a wow this
was perfect get again Fox to left forier and it
didn't go in and hit the crossbar oh how did that
stay out of the net off the glove off the crossbar
and boski says say hello to my little friend and
then a save with the right skate wow wow amazing
Theon popped out high pass across and a good
save by Gibson moving to his right as he denied
machell Matias melli thinks he's got the top of
the net and John Gibson makes a terrific save
just the the very top of the elbow Z ther shoots
it on stop rebound what a save by corello in the
Dy moments of the second eer has a wide open net
and it's a push from right to left by cor pasalo
identifies the open net and just gets enough with
with the left pad to keep it out PKA in backhander
stopped by forsberg and St makes that save on
Skinner forsburg with a great save but watch
the rebound stokesa sticks with it takes away the
lower part of the net gets into that crease and
makes a quality save to keep this at 2-1 ter senko
got the third tally for auto oh what a save by GCO
off Shabbat sliding to his left reaching out with
the glove and he was able to snare it and keep
it out of the net what a save by that your Demco
thomasino bouncing around no that tried to tuck it
in it comes out Yoshi a blast great save Su blood
was down on his backside and somehow made the save
wow what a save turns on Walker just is back Pon
Kenco blocked Atkinson might have saved the goal
there Cam Atkinson saves one here as he gets the
right foot on the Kazo one-timer it's a two on two
Parson makes the move all the way in backhander it
does not go a ridiculously good save with the left
leg on what would have been a highlight re goal
his back leg seals the area blocks Parson and who
had that space more pressure with a drive SA oh
what a stop by vasileski near side as he robs for
Hy look at vasileski look at how much room there
is J in front dger w a save big save by dger stops
Len but can't believe it dger an unbelievable
stop LOM shaking his head what do you do H Bay
now finds kard makes the move W on the tip stopped
by Ryan Nan Hopkins who was there in place to help
out his goenda with a wrap around great defensive
play by nen Hopkins sturk playing toward the board
stopped there by AO pass in front oh big save
great save on fetch toov shurin decides not to
cover the Pucket AO just about makes him pay
huge save moving from left to right on fetch
nikov